The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we'll start off
by going over the Quiz Two
practice questions.
So, (1.1).
In Python a subclass could
override methods of its
superclass.
What say you all?
True?
All right.
There are some repeat people
from last night, so they know
these already.
Standard deviation, coefficient
of variation are
different names for
the same thing.
True or false?
AUDIENCE: False.
PROFESSOR: False.
All right. (1.3.)
AUDIENCE: Can you go over
what the coefficient
of variation is?
PROFESSOR: So, coefficient
of variation.
It is--
I have to write big
for the camera.
Is that right?
People who haven't
asked a question.
It's the other way
around, right?
Coefficient of variation is the
standard deviation divided
by the mean.
What does this tell you?
Like, what sort of information
does the coefficient of
variation tell you?
Anyone?
So, it's another way of telling
if your distribution
is very widely spread.
So, what it's getting at is--
it's trying to help you
compare your standard
deviation against your mean.
Because, let's say that I have a
distribution and its mean is
all the way out at 1.
Let's pick a very
large number.
So it's got a really big
mean, but say its
standard deviation is--
I don't know--
100.
Would you say that that's
widely spread out?
It's pretty tight.
If you're taking--
if this were like, I don't know,
an observatory taking
measurements of deep space and
you've got a fluctuation of
100 for each standard deviation,
you'd probably say
that was pretty good.
And you wouldn't be too
concerned about it, because
you've got a planet out there
that's billions of light years
away or something.
So on the other hand, let's
say that I have another
measurement, and its mean is
somewhere around, say, 50.
And its standard deviation
is 100.
So it's a lot fatter.
You would say that this has a
much wider spread, right?
So it's a way of relating
the standard
deviation to the mean.
And, rule of thumb is if this
is less than or equal to 1,
we're going to say that it's
not too widespread, there's
not a lot of variation.
That's a standard that
Professor Guttag has.
Depending on your purposes
maybe that's too large or
whatever, so but that's what
coefficient of variation is.
Everyone clear on it?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between variance
and standard deviation?
PROFESSOR: The difference
between variance
and standard deviation?
Standard deviation is the
square root of variance.
All right.
Unit testing is useful
for debugging.
What does the audience say?
AUDIENCE: True.
PROFESSOR: OK.
You know what unit testing
is, can you define it?
AUDIENCE: Well, unit testing is
when you use other code to
test your code.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So say you've broken your code
up into nice little functions
like a good programmer.
And you want to make sure that
those functions are giving you
the right values.
What you're doing with unit
testing is, you're writing a
bunch of other code.
Or a little bit of code.
Sometimes a lot, it depends on
how thorough you want to be in
your testing.
And what you have is known
input and known output.
And you're going to feed your
input to the functions you're
testing, and you're going to
make sure that they give you
the output that you're
expecting.
And if they don't give you the
output that you're expecting,
that indicates that there's
probably a bug.
Which also kind of supports the
idea that unit testing is
good for debugging.
And if you are very
conscientious about your code
and doing unit testing, you're
going to run your unit tests
every time you either run your
code or make a change.
Because you might have
inadvertently introduced a bug
into the code that
you're modifying.
So it's a way of verifying, it's
a way of detecting bugs,
and also verifying that any
changes you make in the
process of writing more
functions for your program or
modifying functionality in your
program don't introduce
other bugs.
So in Python, functions cannot
be used as actual parameters.
False.
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, you could just
rephrase the question.
But a better answer
is that functions
are first class citizens.
So they are objects in and of
themselves, and so you can
pass them around to a function
and functions
can make use of them.
So we might see an example of
that later on if you want.
All right.
1.5.
Increasing the size of a hash
table typically increases the
amount of time needed to
locate a variable or
value in the table.
False.
Why?
AUDIENCE: It is Constant type.
PROFESSOR: Right.
The hashing function is
generally constant.
OK.
So, what does this code print?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Six?
AUDIENCE: 11.
PROFESSOR: It's 11.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So what is the
string x actually?
AUDIENCE: Binary?
PROFESSOR: It's the binary
representation of an integer.
And all this code is
doing is, it's just
converting it to a decimal.
And because I came prepared
tonight--
sorta kind of--
I have the code here.
And we can verify it.
Any burning questions
on that problem?
Moving on.
What is the expected
value of g1?
Anyone?
Well, look at what
the code's doing.
Did someone--
AUDIENCE: What's "gauze,"
that function?
We haven't used that one.
PROFESSOR: Gauss is--
AUDIENCE: Oh, Gauss.
PROFESSOR: --a method on the
random object that draws a
random value from a Gaussian
distribution
that has a mean at--
well, in this case, mean--
and a standard deviation
of s-t-d-dev,
whatever you put in there.
So maybe for this example, if
I wanted to draw a random
value from this distribution,
which I said had a mean of 50
and a standard deviation
of 100, I would say
random.Gauss 50, 100.
So, in answering the question
(3.1), what do people think?
What about (3.2)?
100,000.
So they're both the same.
But they both have a different
standard deviation.
So what this is getting
at is, it's getting
you to look at this.
So this code is straight
from the question.
And all I'm going to do is, I'm
going to plot a histogram
of what this function
produces.
And also I'm going to run it a
number of times and verify
that I am getting 100,000
in general.
Python.
There we go.
So it's not exactly 100,000,
but it's close enough.
I mean, we're not going
to be too upset.
So this picture here shows the
actual values that were drawn
when I repeated the experiment
a number of times.
So I don't know if you can see
on the screen but there's this
big, really thin, vertical
line here.
Those are the results from
the Gaussian with
a 0 standard deviation.
So everything was
100,000 exactly.
And then these red blocks
here, this is with the
standard deviation of 20.
Any questions on this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between a normal
distribution and a Gaussian
distribution?
PROFESSOR: The name.
The question was, what's the
difference between a normal
distribution and a Gaussian
distribution.
And it's just, it's
a different name.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: How I
came across it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
How are we supposed to see
that in this problem,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, if you look
at the plots, which I
apparently killed--
so let me pull them up again--
All right.
So the thing that you want
to know about Gaussian
distributions is that, at the
mean, is the value that's the
most probable.
So its peak is at the mean.
And so if you're taking a
1000 numbers from this
distribution, then if you know
which number you're expecting
to see with the highest
probability--
I'm not sure if this sentence
is grammatical any more--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So really standard deviation
doesn't really have anything
to do with it.
PROFESSOR: What it's going
to affect is, it's
going to tell you that--
like, if you have a standard
deviation of 10 versus 20,
it's just going to tell
you what the spread
of the curve is.
But it's not going to change
the expected value.
So, why don't I actually
demonstrate that?
Because I'm a fan of visuals
and not necessarily good at
English tonight.
All right.
So all I did in the code was,
I just changed the standard
deviation of the first
distribution to
be 10 versus 20.
And what you can see from the
plots are that the value with
the highest probability is still
centered at 100,000.
But the first plot, as opposed
to the first time we ran this
with a 0 standard deviation,
is a little
bit more spread out.
And the plot with 20, for the
standard deviation, is even
more spread out, than it.
But they both have the highest
probability at 100,000 or
centered at 100,000.
AUDIENCE: So it's like, if you
have a mean for g1 of 100, or
g2 of 200, then you would
expect 200,000 for g2?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if instead you had a mean
of, say, 200 for the second
distribution, versus 100,
you'd expect them in two
completely separate places.
And you'd get an expected
value that's
100,000 versus 200,000.
So here close to 100,000, close
to 200,000 and then see
what my distribution is.
All right.
We good on this?
So moving on.
Question (4).
What is the probability of the
final value of num6 being 0?
AUDIENCE: 9/10 to the 10.
PROFESSOR: 9 over 10,
the whole thing to
the 10th power, right?
OK.
So does anyone not see
why that's the case?
So I'm going to explain
that anyway.
So what this code is doing is,
for 10 times its drawing an
integer from 0 to 9.
A random integer.
It's a uniform distribution.
And it's counting the number
of times that the integer
drawn is 6.
And it's incrementing
a counter.
So the question can be rephrased
as, what's the
probability that no 6's were
drawn 10 times out of a pool
of 10 integers?
And the way you can figure it
out is on one pool where, say
I had a 10 sided dice.
On one roll, what's
the probability of
not getting a 6?
It's going to be 9
over 10, right?
And if you do that 10 times.
9 over 10 times 9 over 10 times
9 over 10, that gives
you 9 over 10 to
the 10th power.
And because this is a code
class, we have a
demonstration.
So here's the answer that
we hand-jammed or
that we just discussed.
And now here is a function
count of 6.
And it's the code that you
see in problem (4).
And all I'm going to
do is, I'm going to
run a number of trials.
And I'm going to count the
number of trials that come up
0, and increment a
count numzero's.
And then I'm going to say,
this is what I think the
probability of getting a 0 is.
And then we'll compare
the two numbers.
OK so that's the probability
that we count
9/10 to the 10th power.
And then this is the estimated
probability that we got from
running this function
100,000 times.
So we good on this problem?
AUDIENCE: Instead of solving
it the way that you guys
solved it, can you solve
it by saying that
the problem's also--
that it's 1 minus the
probability that 6
will always be picked?
PROFESSOR: That you will
see at least one 6?
1 minus the probability that
you'll see at least one 6?
AUDIENCE: No, never mind.
PROFESSOR: You can solve
it in different ways.
It's just this way is--
I think, probably, this way of
thinking about it is probably
more intuitive.
AUDIENCE: When would you want to
solve this kind of problem
with [INAUDIBLE], instead
of when it says it's not
something, to use 1 minus
the probability?
That it is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, my answer
would be when it
makes sense to you.
Some problems are easier viewed
in the negative light,
which is what you're saying
as 1 minus whatever.
And some problems are
better solved in a
straightforward fashion.
So it's whatever tool
gets the job done.
I don't have a general rule
of thumb for you.
Maybe there's a course
18 person who does.
AUDIENCE: So this problem, would
we possibly be asked,
what is the probability that
it'll end up being 1?
Or does it necessarily matter
which of those 10 came up 6?
And how would you show that, if
we were going to be asked
that question?
PROFESSOR: Well.
One, I haven't seen the quiz.
So I can't give you
a definite.
But you could be asked,
instead of using
6, maybe say, 1.
Is that going to really
change anything?
AUDIENCE: No.
I guess I meant that one
of those 10 outcomes
ends up being a 6.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: I can do it if, they
say the fifth trial is a 6.
But just 1 of those 10 trials
being a 6, I don't know how to
write properly?
PROFESSOR: So what's the
probability that you get 1 of
the trials as exactly 6?
Or exactly 1 of the trials
comes up as 6?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Well, one way of
thinking of it is-- so we
calculated 9/10.
That's the probability that
6 doesn't come up, right?
So what's the probability
that 6 will come up?
1/10.
So instead of doing 9/10 to the
10th power, it would be
9/10 to the 9th power
times 1/10, right?
AUDIENCE: OK, that'll
account for.
Thanks
PROFESSOR: And because I'm never
very comfortable with
this stuff, why don't
we do a simulation?
So this is what we're saying.
Exactly one 6 comes up.
And I'm going to
set this to 1.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that saying that
it's less likely that one
6 comes up than zero
6s come up?
Is it?
That's true?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Because you're looking
for exactly--
you're looking for a sequence
of 10 events where exactly 1
of those of events is a 6.
Which seems more unlikely than,
say, getting everything
that's not a 6.
So I want to verify this.
AUDIENCE: Why is it 9/10
to the 9th [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because we're
asking, if I roll this
10-sided dice 10 times, what's
the probability that exactly
one of those rolls is going
to come up with 6?
And so what we're asking is,
what is the probability that I
roll the dice 9 times and it
doesn't come up with 6?
And then what's the probability
that on the
remaining roll, that
it comes up as 6?
Which is 1/10.
So let's see if I'm
in the ballpark.
Did I make a mistake?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
where if there's ten different
ways-- so it would be like--
PROFESSOR: Oh, yeah.
So yeah, you're right.
That's why I don't
like that stuff.
So yeah, it's a little bit more
complicated than that.
AUDIENCE: You only counted
one case of getting--
PROFESSOR: That's right.
So in this, I'm only
counting one case.
There's multiple ways that
exactly one dice
could come up 6.
So the answer is more
complicated.
AUDIENCE: So would you
just multiply by 10?
Because there's 10
different places?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So actually, that's
what we got, so--
we'll just do this.
Well, of course that's
going to come up.
But the simulation gives us the
same answer as what we've
just come up with discussing.
OK, problem solved.
Did that work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Probability
can be tricky.
AUDIENCE: So essentially,
you could just take the
probability that 9 of
the rolls aren't 6,
and leave it at that?
Because you multiply it
by 10 [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can also do it that way.
So again, there's
multiple ways to
think about the problem.
So she was saying, instead
of multiplying by
10, we just say that--
we take the probability that we
have 9 rolls that aren't 6.
And that works too.
That's what she just
pointed out.
So these parts cancel
each other out.
It's basically--
it is the same thing as this.
Yay.
All right.
Are we good on this question?
Problem (5).
It was matching plots.
So you have three
functions here.
You have a polynomial,
or two polynomials.
One's a cubic, one's
a quintic.
And one's an exponential.
There are a couple ways that
you could go about
solving this one.
One is to plug values
in and kind of match
them up with the plots.
Another is to look at the
axis of the plots.
So this exponential function
here, if we were to have it on
two linear axes, the x-axis
and the y-axis for both
linear, you'd see the expected
curve upward sharply.
But if you notice, a couple
of the plots are
in a semi-log y-axis.
So if you put an exponential
with a linear x-axis and a
logarithmic y-axis, what
would you expect the
plot to look like?
It would be a straight
line, right.
So what that tells us is that if
we look at the bottom plot,
we have something with
a straight line.
So, bottom plot is the
third function.
So, exponential.
And then for the remaining two
functions, there are a couple
methods that you would use,
or you could use.
One is to plug values in and see
where the points wind up
and compare them
with the plots.
Another way to think about it is
that one of the plots is on
a semi-log and another plot is
on just both linear axes.
And if you plot a polynomial
that's not exponential on a
logarithmic y-axis, what
would you expect the
curve to look like?
It should look somewhat similar
to a logarithm.
So with that in mind,
you could then start
plugging points in.
And what you would come up
with is that the second
function is this
top plot here.
And the middle plot here
is the first function.
Is there anyone who's
lost on that?
Uh-oh.
AUDIENCE: Wait, why?
So you have two quadratic
functions, right?
One and two are quadratic?
PROFESSOR: They're
polynomials.
They're not exponential.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then the third one's
exponential.
And the reason why the third
one's linear is because when
you plot an exponential--
PROFESSOR: If you plot an
exponential with a linear
x-axis and a logarithmic
y-axis, it should be a
straight line.
Right?
Or a straightish line.
AUDIENCE: Why?
PROFESSOR: It's the way
the math works out.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Any other
questions?
All right, we'll move
onto the next one.
What does the following
code print?
AUDIENCE: 16.
And then square root
of [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Close.
So I don't actually
have the answer.
Well, not written down.
But I have the code, so I'm just
going to run the code.
So you're close.
Shall we spend some time
stepping through this code,
understanding it?
All right.
So, what question (6) does is,
it creates a class hierarchy.
And at the top of it, it
has the shape class.
Which has just two methods,
double underbar EQ and double
underbar GE.
That was just defined as
equals operator and the
greater than or equal
operator for shapes.
In terms of their area.
So what this is saying is that
two shapes are equal if their
areas are equal, and a shape S1
is going to be larger than
another shape if its area is
larger than the other shape.
So if I had--
well let's go down and
we'll get to that.
Square, subclass of shape.
It is what it says it is.
It's a square.
And it has a side.
And its area is what
you'd expect it to
be, the side squared.
And circle is just defined--
it just has a radius, and its
area is what you would
expect it to be.
There is a function here, f.
And it takes a parameter, l.
And I --
if you look at the code here and
you kind of walk through
it -- l would have to
be either a list
or a tuple of elements.
Doesn't have to necessarily
be shapes.
But this first line is just
going to return none if the
list is empty.
And then these next lines are
going to, one it's going to
set the first element equal to
x, and then iterate through
each element in l.
And then if the element it's
looking at is larger than x
it's going to set x
to the element.
So what this function is doing
is finding the largest element
in the list.
Everyone follow that?
So, this should be pretty
straightforward.
As should this.
This part my trip
some people up.
So, this obviously creates
an empty list.
What this does is, it creates
a dictionary of class names.
And what it's saying is
that for a key of 0,
the class is circle.
And for a key of one the
class is square.
Everyone see that?
This loop here iterates
for 10 times.
And it appends 10 elements.
And then each of those elements
are defined by this
shapes dictionary.
On each iteration, it's going to
take the modulus of i, the
index, or the number.
And if it's a 0, it's going to
construct whatever class the
dictionary of shapes returns.
So if it's an even number,
it's going to be circle.
And if it's an odd number
is going to be a square.
Everyone follow that?
Does no-one follow that?
OK.
Or does anyone not
follow that?
Got my logic messed up.
All right.
So now what we have here
is a list of shapes.
And then all this does is it's
going to print which shape.
Is it going to be the fourth
or the fifth shape?
Fifth, right?
Because we've started
indexing it at 0.
So this number is
obviously even.
So this should be a circle
shape, or a circle class.
And what should its radius be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
And then this line here is just
going call the function
f, which is going to find
the larger shape.
Which is determined
by its area.
And in this particular instance,
it's going to be a
circle with radius eight.
Once you figure out what f does,
this is actually not
such a hard problem.
So the key to understanding this
one is figuring out what
f is actually doing.
And you'll probably see a
problem or two on the exam
that's written like this, where
the function has been
obfuscated.
So it doesn't have nice
little variable names.
If we were writing this
for real, it would be
something like that.
AUDIENCE: Wait, what was
the radius on L?
It was--
PROFESSOR: Radius on L?
AUDIENCE: Or not radius.
Like, L4 was circled.
And was that all it was,
it was just a circle?
PROFESSOR: With radius 4.
AUDIENCE: With radius 4?
OK, that's what I thought.
PROFESSOR: All right.
AUDIENCE: How many of those
special underbar functions
have we seen?
Have we seen anything besides
edit string and [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So, how many
of the double underbar
functions have you seen?
That's a good question.
You've seen a lot, right?
The ones that I would be
familiar with definitely INIT
definitely EQ, GE and
definitely STR.
You might want to be familiar
with this, LE.
So what is LE?
What do you think that does?
Less than or equal to.
Less than.
So it's this the opposite
of GE, right?
I think there's also an
LT, so less than.
And GT.
It's fairly logical.
And historically you don't need
to have these memorized.
I've never seen a question where
you've actually had to
produce code that uses double
underbar on the quiz.
You just have to understand
what it's doing
if you can see it.
Like, in a code reading
exercise.
And the conventions are fairly
straightforward to understand.
Can I move on?
AUDIENCE: Can you scroll
down a little bit?
Where it says print L4,
or I guess print FL.
Does it automatically just print
the string function?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So you're asking why
I don't have this.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: So in this flavor
of Python, and if you don't
have an explicit conversion to
string, Python will look for
the underbar STR function
if it exists.
If it doesn't exist then you get
that weird object at blah,
blah, blah.
AUDIENCE: Right.
PROFESSOR: Any other
questions?
AUDIENCE: What list are
you reading up on top?
PROFESSOR: Are you confused
because it's the same name?
AUDIENCE: Maybe.
I don't know.
So the third thing
that [INAUDIBLE].
I understand the second thing,
circle with radius 4.
But how do you get that
circle of radius 8?
PROFESSOR: Well, the way we
get that is, f of l--
f is the function, right?
AUDIENCE: Right, and it produces
the largest element
of the list.
And the list, L, contains
0 to 9?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So we could actually print
out what L contains.
AUDIENCE: Why isn't it square?
Isn't 9 [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Why don't we do it?
All right.
So all it's going to do is, it's
going to print out all
the shapes in the list
and their areas.
I've got stuff at the top.
So this is the first shape.
And then, as we move down the
list, we have square with side
1, circle with radius 2, 3, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And then, this is the area of
the circle with radius 8
versus the area of a
square with side 9.
So, and it depends on--
the reason why it works this
way is that this is greater
than or equal to operator is
defined in terms of the area
method of the shapes.
Does that--
AUDIENCE: So wait.
What is this doing then?
L is a list of areas?
PROFESSOR: No, L is
a list of shapes.
It's a list of subclasses
of shapes.
AUDIENCE: So you're feeding
f this list of shapes.
Oh, and to compare if S and
L [? into that list ?]
is greater.
And for equal to x, do you have
to use the greater than
or equal to--
PROFESSOR: Operator, right.
AUDIENCE: --method, the
class of shapes
which compares areas?
PROFESSOR: Mm-hm.
Now, I might regret this.
I think this'll work.
Yep.
It works.
So, you see this weirdness
I have here?
It's showing pretty explicitly
that I'm
calling this a GE operator.
It's just so--
this is really just shorthand
for that.
Syntactic sugar.
It's easier to look at.
Easier to understand.
And to even drive that
point further home--
whenever that GE, whenever that
comparison is done, it's
going to print out I'm here.
So it is actually getting
called and not
just blowing smoke.
Have we beaten this
problem to death?
Last problem.
So, I'm actually not a huge
fan of this problem.
But the way I think of it
is, it's the number
guessing game, right?
So I say to you, I'm thinking of
a number between 0 and 100.
Or in this case, maxVal.
And your job is to guess, as
quickly as possible, what
number I'm thinking of.
The only thing I can tell you
is that you give me a guess
and I'll tell you if it's higher
or lower, or if it is
the answer.
So if I'm thinking of a
number between 0 and
100, what's the strategy?
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Binary search.
AUDIENCE: Binary search, yeah.
PROFESSOR: Binary
search, right?
So you're going to start
in the middle.
You're going to start at 50, and
you're going to say-- and
I'm going to say, well,
no, the number I'm
thinking of is lower.
So now you're going to guess
between 0 and 50, 25.
And I'm going to say
it's higher.
Now you're going to guess
between 25 and 50.
I don't know, I didn't actually
think of a number.
But you get the idea, right?
So this problem is asking you to
implement a binary search.
And comp.guess here
is functioning
as me in this problem.
It knows a number and you write
a program that's going
to guess it, which
is find.number.
So, there are multiple ways
to do this problem.
Here is my solution.
This is just an implementation
of comp guess.
At the beginning, set a maximum
value of 100,000.
And I'm going to guess the magic
number, or I'm going to
choose a random number
from between-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you say binary
search, is that the same thing
as bisection search?
PROFESSOR: It's the same idea.
But the way that I differentiate
binary search
from bisection search is that
you do a binary search on a
finite list of elements,
of sorted elements.
So I might have a list of names
in alphabetical order,
or a list of numbers
in ascending order.
And I would do a binary
search on that list.
With bisection search, it's not
necessarily a finite list
of numbers or elements
that I'm looking at.
It's, I know that the answer
exists within a lower and an
upper bound, and I'm going to
divide that search space in
half successively or iteratively
to find that
actual value.
But it's not necessarily a
finite list of elements
between those bounds.
That's good?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: So this is
one implementation.
You can do it any
number of ways.
This numSteps thing, you
wouldn't need to have.
It's just for me to illustrate
some stuff.
So I'm going to start
at 0, and I'm
going to start at maxVal.
And then I'm going to
keep iterating.
While I don't have,
or while I haven't
reached the answer, basically.
So, I'm going to make my
guess in the middle.
And then if comp.guess tells me
that it's higher, or that
my guess is too low, basically,
then I'm going to
set my upper--
sorry, if my guess is too high,
then I'm going to set my
upper bound to my guess.
And then I'm going to search
in the middle from there.
And then if it tells me that my
guess is too high, then I'm
going to search in
the upper region.
Otherwise, that means I've
made the correct
guess and I'm done.
So, very simple.
The key part of this problem
that tells you that you should
use binary search, though, is
that it stipulates you need to
have a log maxVal algorithm.
And binary search is
a log N algorithm.
I mean, you could do find number
in a linear search, but
it would be fairly
inefficient.
All right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] just guess
one number, then go--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, start at 0--
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
guess 1, you guess
2, then guess 3.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So you just keep incrementing
by one.
AUDIENCE: If it didn't specify,
oh, it should run log
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], would it be
OK if we had used the word
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: If it didn't specify
the complexity, then
yeah, you could use whatever
search you deemed appropriate.
But because it said it
needs to be log N --
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Are you going
to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Not in this
particular case.
Because we're dealing with
integers anyway.
So all these operations
are going to
result in integer results.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to ever
be able to get to the
highest number?
PROFESSOR: So if it were,
like, 99,000?
Is that what you're asking?
AUDIENCE: If the number
were maxVal.
PROFESSOR: Well, we'll see.
I might have it wrong in my
implementation, always possible.
If I do, I'd probably take
one point off me.
Yeah, so I have a bug.
So I am actually--
AUDIENCE: When it divides, it
rounds it down [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So I have a bug.
And I'm not going to try and
fix it right now, but yeah.
If I were grading this and this
were my solution, I'd
dock me a point or two.
AUDIENCE: What's your error?
PROFESSOR: My error is that
because of this the way that I
get my guess here, I'm never
going to get to max val.
If the computer chose maxVal as
its guess, then I'd never
get to that.
So yeah, you caught me.
AUDIENCE: A friend of mine
looked at this and was like,
oh, you should define another
function to solve it.
Is that kind of thing actually
allowed on the
exam at all, or no?
PROFESSOR: Well, why did your
friend think you need to find
another function?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
exactly sure.
It was supposed to be
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Did they say define
a recursive function?
AUDIENCE: I think that's what
I was trying to do.
PROFESSOR: So I'm solving
it iteratively.
You really can write a
recursive function.
And in this case, because
we've given you the
specification for find number,
you'd probably write something
like find number helper, and
have whatever additional
parameters you needed in order
to support the recursion.
AUDIENCE: So you can
do that or no?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
We'd be fine with that.
The point is that you write a
function that runs in log
maxVal time.
AUDIENCE: Because at the top it
says that the magic number
is in range maxVal, doesn't
that mean that the number
would not ever be maxVal?
PROFESSOR: Let me see.
Actually, yeah.
Because it would be 0 to 999--
or 999,999.
Well, I'm not sure
if this actually
constitutes a bug or not.
So I'd have to do
unit testing.
I don't have any test cases.
Which is, again, back
to unit testing.
You have a question or--?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Could you do this by saying
your guess equals choose a
random number between
high and low?
PROFESSOR: You could.
But it would have--
the analyzing complexity would
be problematic, I would think.
Doing it this way, by guessing
right in the middle, you know
it's going to be log
maxVal complexity.
If you were to choose a random
number between low and high,
I'm not sure what that would
do to the complexity.
It would make the analysis a
little bit more intricate.
And if this were the actual quiz
and you put that as your
answer we'd probably take
a fair number of
points off for it.
There are people who
do study algorithms
that do that, though.
They use random numbers in
order to [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the values.
So we're done with the quiz.
And now we've got a list
of topics to go over.
So, let's start at the top.
The first subject that was
listed-- so all you got the
list of quiz topics for the
quiz, I'm assuming?
Did all of you look at it?
The first topic is algorithms.
And I have big-O notation,
exhaustive enumeration, guess
and check, successive
approximation, divide and
conquer, binary search, merge
sort, hashing, orders of
growth, and amortized
analysis.
So, first come, first serve.
What do people want to see?
AUDIENCE: Hashing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Hashing and amortized
analysis.
PROFESSOR: Hashing and
amortized analysis.
OK.
So why don't I start with
hashing, because
that's pretty easy.
The idea behind hashing is that
you have a function, and
it's going to take some input.
And it's going to compute
an address of some sort.
And let's imagine that I have
a data structure that has a
number of buckets arranged
one after the other.
What hashing does is, it says I
have this input s, or a key,
if you will.
And I'm going to compute
an address like a
number of some sort.
And it's going to, say,
wind up here.
And this relates to Python
because this is how
dictionaries are implemented.
So this s here is going to be
the key that you give the
dictionary.
And then it'll compute a
location for this bucket where
it's going to put the value.
So, the idea--
what makes these hashing
functions valuable, especially
with respect to dictionaries, is
that you can check for the
presence of a key or a value
in constant time.
Because the hashing function
is more or less constant.
And once you have an address
into the data structure, it's
very easy to compute the
location where you're going to
put something.
So, I'm not sure--
does that kind of help you?
You don't need to know hashing
in great detail.
You're not going to need to know
the hashing function for
like a string, or the hashing
function for a tuple or
something like that.
The main points that you need to
get from hashing is that it
computes an address into
this data structure.
It's a constant time thing.
And that's about it, actually.
If you have those two
concepts down--
well, also, three that that's
how dictionaries are
implemented--
if you have those in your mind
for hashing, you'll be good.
Anyone have any other questions
for hashing?
AUDIENCE: So we never have to
like write a hashing function.
It's more like [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This is so that you
know what it is, and when you
see it in the future, if you see
it in the future, you're
not totally lost.
You have an idea of
what it's doing.
You can define your own hash
functions, but we're not going
to require that of you
in this course.
So that's hashing, basically.
And all you need to
know for the quiz.
So for amortized analysis, the
idea behind amortized analysis
is that you have--
maybe you have a known sequence
of operations.
And you're trying to find what
the worst case runtime for
that sequence of
operations is.
And you might have a bunch of
operations that are really,
really low cost, or
low complexity.
And one really expensive one.
And for our purposes, we're
trying to find this--
find which of these operations
is the dominating factor for
the complexity.
So the example I would use is,
let's say that I have the task
of searching for an element
in a big list of elements.
So we know two basic search
algorithms for this, right?
We know a linear search, where
we go one at a time through
each of the elements.
And what's the complexity
of that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Just the length
of [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: It's going to be
linear in terms of the number
of elements in the list.
We also know binary search.
What's the complexity
of binary search?
AUDIENCE: Log N.
PROFESSOR: Log N. Now, there's
a problem with binary search.
It has a requirement.
Will binary search work on a
list that is not sorted?
No.
You require it to be sorted.
So, we've talked about
sorting in class.
He covered it during
the lecture.
For basic sorting that we've
seen, the lower bound, the
complexity of the sorting
algorithms is N log N. So
merge sort will be an
N log N algorithm.
So, when--
let's say that we just need
to do one search, right?
Do I really want to
use binary search?
Why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because I have
to sort it first.
And if I just do--
if I do I have to sort
and then search, and
this is going to be--
whereas if I do a linear search,
I just have search.
And for just a single search,
for binary search, this is
going to dominate
my complexity.
But, let's say that I'm going
to do a million searches.
Now, it might behoove me to
actually sort this first.
Because I only have to
sort the list once.
And then I can do as many
searches as I want.
So, in the grand scheme of
things, if I'm doing a million
searches, then linear search
is a really poor choice.
And binary search would
be my best option.
And this is about as deep
as we want to go
with amortized analysis.
It's this idea that there's a
certain point at which one
algorithm becomes more important
than another
algorithm, because the
composition of its operations
kind of determines, it changes
as you increase the number of
elements you're working with
the number of times you're
going to do the operation.
That's kind of what you
need to understand
for amortized analysis.
And it can be used in other
types of analyses, but we're
not going to get into that.
All right.
What other topics do we want
to go over for algorithms?
We've got big-O notation,
exhaustive enumeration, divide
and conquer.
Successive approximation,
merge sort,
and orders of growth.
AUDIENCE: Can we go
over merge sort?
PROFESSOR: You want to
go over merge sort?
OK.
So-- and today actually,
I have my code.
So merge sort is a divide
and conquer algorithm.
And the idea is that
I am going to
take a list of elements.
And I'm going to divide
the list in half.
So I'm going to get a left list
and a right list, and
they're unsorted.
And then I'm going to call
merge.sort on them.
And I'm going to keep
recursively calling merge sort
until I have one element or
no elements in the list.
And then I'm going to
return the list.
After I do a merge sort on the
left and right halves, I'm
going to merge them.
And the merge operation is just
going to start at the
beginning of the left and right
halves of the list, and
it's going to append the
smaller element at the
beginning of each of the lists
to result until it gets to the
end of the lists.
So I'll try a blackboard
demonstration in a second.
Or explanation in a second.
So, this before parameter,
all this is doing is it's
determining the order
of the elements.
So it's saying that left should
come before right.
It'll return true if left should
come before right, and
false if right should
come before left.
So, intuitively, because I don't
think that was a very
good explanation,
let's say that I
have a list of elements.
And they're unsorted.
All right.
So it's an unsorted
list of elements.
When merge.sort first starts,
it's going to divide this list
into left and right halves.
So basically it's going to
take the middle here.
And then it's going to call
itself, on this left half and
then on this right half.
And it's going to
keep doing this.
It's going to divide this
half into say --
5, 2, 1.
Now, when it gets to these
little single elements, it's
going to do something
interesting.
It's going to merge these two.
So when it gets down to these
single elements, it's just
going to return the list as
is, it's not going to do
anything to them.
And then the code after
this, division, is
going to merge them.
And the way it merges them is,
it's going to start at the
beginning of these two lists.
And it's going to say, is this
element larger or smaller than
this element?
Or is it going to come
before this element?
And it's going to construct
a merged list.
And then return that
as its result.
So this is going to come down.
So now at this point it's
popping back up the stack.
It's going to return this.
It's going to merge
these two lists.
Starts at the beginning
of both lists.
One comes before two.
And then this list is done,
so now it only has
this list to do.
After each merge step, these
lists are going to be sorted.
So now where are we at?
So now let's do this guy.
So this guy gets merged
into 6 and 9.
And then this guy, I
didn't divide up.
So, bad on me.
So we're going to merge those
two single element lists.
Now these get merged.
So these guys are going
to get merged.
So, this is going to become, I
think my tree got messed up a
little bit.
Now we're going to merge
these lists.
So we're going to start
at the beginning.
1 comes before 3.
First element is 1.
2 comes before 3.
Now we're here in this list.
We're still at the beginning
of this list.
3 comes before 5.
5 comes before 7.
And we're here.
6 comes before 7.
Then we have 7.
And then 9 comes before 10.
Now we're done with this list.
So now we have 10, 13.
And at the end of the last
merge the list is sorted.
So, I'm not sure how
clear that was.
AUDIENCE: What happens if
there's [UNINTELLIGIBLE] to
begin with?
Like all of your split equally
into [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
What if there's one more
element at the top,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
Do you know what I mean, like,
there'd be one left over?
PROFESSOR: What do you mean?
So there's an odd number of
elements in the list?
So you would just get
an uneven split.
So your left sub-list might
have 6 elements.
Say you have 11 elements
in the list.
Left element would have 6,
or left list would have 6
elements and then the right
list would have 5.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
then that would
split with 3 and 2.
And then the 2 would split to
1 and 1, the 3 would split
into 1 and 2, and then the
2 would split again?
PROFESSOR: And then the 1 would
actually make a call,
but it would be an empty list.
It would split, but one of them
would be an empty list.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
So and then it would
just get--
PROFESSOR: And that's kind of
what happened with my tree.
I didn't go all the way
down on some of the
branches of my tree.
I mean, the main idea behind
merge.sort is that you split
the list in half, whatever
size it this.
And then you merge sort
those separate halves.
And merge sort is going to do
the same thing with those
separate halves.
It's going to split
them in half.
And sort those halves until it
gets to the smallest case,
which is an empty list or
just a single element.
And then it's just going to
start merging these lists.
AUDIENCE: Right, I was just
wondering what happened
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you'd split it
into 2 and 1, and then that
merge sort would be
like 1 and 1.
And then this 1 would split it
into a list of 1 and nothing.
That's all.
And then the merge between
that's obvious, right?
AUDIENCE: So in the merge sort
lecture notes, at one point,
lambda is used.
Can you explain a bit
how this works?
PROFESSOR: Does he actually
use a lambda?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Why is it useful?
I guess [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ah.
He used lambda.
OK, Python has these functions
called lambda functions.
And what they are essentially
are like one-liner bits of
code that return a value.
So let's see.
I can't believe he
used lambda.
I'm trying to think of where
I would actually use them.
Like, an example.
And I don't have one off
the top of my head.
You're not going to see
a lambda on the quiz.
The syntax is not
too difficult.
It's basically, so,
like lambda x.
And then it's going to return,
like, x-squared.
This is going to create
a function.
And it can be something like, I
assign this lambda function
to a variable square.
And I'm going to pull
up a separate--
So I'm creating a
function square.
But instead of writing something
like this, I write
it as this.
And ...
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Do you have to save it
before it lets you run it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's, again, what I'm doing.
I'm just trying to think
of a witty name.
I'm actually stunned that he
whipped lambda out in lecture.
So really it's a
way of defining
these one-liner functions.
Python's lambda functions are
kind of broken, at least in
the 2.5, 2.6, 2.7,
2.x versions.
3.0, 3.x versions of Python, I
think, actually do away with
lambda because they
were broken.
You find lambda functions in
a lot of other programming
languages like Lisp or Scheme.
And you're never going to
see this on a quiz.
But if you want to learn
more about them you
can look it up online.
AUDIENCE: While you're running
the function, what is the
[INAUDIBLE]
The same thing?
Oh, OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I had it there as an
illustration that the
functions are-- they're
functionally equivalent.
And it actually serves to
illustrate another point, that
functions are objects and you
can sign them and pass them
around and stuff.
But lambda functions on their
own, you're not going to need
to know that piece of linguistic
Python, Pythonese.
Bad sentence.
You're not going to
need to know it.
Does that work?
OK.
I'm going to have to ask him
about that, because I can't
believe he used lambda
in lecture.
AUDIENCE: In one of the
lecture notes, he used
something called x-range.
PROFESSOR: x-range.
AUDIENCE: What does that do?
PROFESSOR: Did he talk about
generator objects or iterate?
Or yield?
You haven't seen those?
OK.
So what you're asking is,
something like that.
He used something like that.
The difference between range
and x-range is that range
returns a list of integers,
and x-range returns in
generator object.
And I know that really meant
a whole lot to you.
So let's say that I assign ...
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah. that's what
I'm going to show.
So if I do print list of
integers, or list of numbers,
it's actually going to print
the list of numbers.
Someone fall back there?
So it's actually going
to print that list.
Now, if I do something like--
pretty sure this is not
going to print the...
The reason is that if you look
at the type of the object
that's returned, it's--
well, x-range doesn't really
help much either.
Why does he do this to me?
It's a way of-- so let's say
that you have a list of a
billion elements, or numbers,
or things that you need to
iterate over in a for loop.
It's probably not a good idea
to bring all of those into
memory at once.
So, or to necessarily keep
them all around.
You want--
that's where things like
x-range come in.
So, let's do this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] for i
in x-range 10 [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if I do this, it's going
to be the same as if
I were to do this.
It's going to have the same
functional effect, but the
difference comes in-- let's
say that I were to do
something like this.
Lot of numbers, right?
I'm hoping Python crashes
on this, because
this is my whole point.
Yeah, so there's
too many items.
But let's see if I do
it with x-range.
I should probably comment
this out.
I chose a really too large
number, didn't I?
I'm going to find a number
that has too many list
elements, but Python can still
feel comfortable constructing
an x-range out of...
The point is that there's
a certain
point, a certain number.
I don't know if it's going
to do that comfortably.
So you see this little delay
that's occurring?
Actually, this kind
of a long delay?
It's actually hanging up
on this range command.
Because it's actually
constructing this list object
with all these integers in it.
So, let's say I do this.
Are you going to need to know
the exact difference?
No.
Is there a difference?
Yes.
Am I prepared to explain
it exactly, right now?
Not really.
Previous iterations of this
class have covered the yield
statement in Python, which
allows you to create functions
that create generator
objects that...
You did yield?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, then you
should know about this.
So range is going to give
you a list of integers.
x-range is going to give you a
generator object that uses
yields to produce
these integers.
So let me see if can
rescue my machine.
All right.
So, he covered something
like that with yield?
So if I were to, say,
do i in my x-range--
back to where I was.
My x-range does the exact same
thing that x-range does.
Now, as I said before, if I do
a list, or if I do range,
that's going to be
a list, right?
If I assign this to ...
see that?
That's what the yield statement
does for you.
It produces that generator and
that's how x-range functions.
So, basically it allows you to
do some interesting things.
Like, in this case, it's not too
interesting because it's
just returning one integer
after the other.
But let's say that
I wanted to do --
def my_squares.
All that's going to do is return
these squares of all
the numbers between 0 and max N.
So if I were to do this, it
should print out all
the squares--
or the square root of all the
numbers between 0 and 9.
Make sense?
So that's what yield gets you.
Those are generator objects.
And that's how x-range works.
That's how it's different
than range.
Does that make sense
to everyone?
OK.
I don't need to beat that
to death any longer?
I was not expecting
that question.
OK.
What should we go over next?
Is everyone comfortable
with orders of growth?
All right.
The next major topic area I
have is linguistic issues.
So, this covers stuff like
exceptions, polymorphism,
classes and objects.
So people want to
go over classes?
Objects?
Polymorphism?
OK.
AUDIENCE: What's polymorphism?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we'll
get to that.
So before my computer
crashed--
all right.
So here are some class
definitions.
So I have a shape object, and
I've defined two methods, area
and perimeter.
They currently do nothing
except for raise not
implemented errors.
And now I have to find
a class hierarchy.
I have a rectangle class that
inherits from shape.
So shape is a superclass
of rectangle.
Rectangle is a subclass
of shape.
This also says--
well, let me ask the question,
is shape a rectangle?
It's not rhetorical.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Not necessarily.
Is rectangle a shape?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It's an easy question.
It's not a trick question.
In the rectangle class,
I have an INIT method.
It just takes the length
and the width.
So computing the area
is really easy.
And then computing the perimeter
is also very easy.
And now I have a string
representation which is just
rectangle with the
length and width.
Ellipse inherits from shape
and it has one radius--
or one, the long axis
and the short axis.
And computing the area for
that is pretty easy.
Computing the perimeter, on the
other hand, I had to look
it up online.
So if you're interested in the
formula I used go take a look
at this website.
Again, I have a string method.
And then now we have a square
which inherits from rectangle.
Because square is just a special
case of a rectangle.
And so I'm going to reuse it.
I'm just going to make both
lengths the same.
That make sense to everyone?
And I don't need to override the
area and perimeter because
they're pretty easy
to understand.
Or they're the same.
And then circle.
It just inherits from ellipse,
and same thing.
I'm just going to reuse the
stuff that I have in ellipse.
All right.
I've defined a bag
of shapes here.
Circles, squares, rectangles.
Rectangles.
Lots of stuff.
Now, to answer your question,
what polymorphism allows me to
do is, it allows me to treat
subclasses that share a
particular superclass, or a
parent class, the same.
So I've defined an area method
on the shape class.
And all of my subclasses,
rectangle, ellipse, circle and
square, inherit from
this superclass.
And some of them override area,
some of them don't.
It doesn't really
matter to me.
What matters to me is that if I
have a bag of these shapes,
I know that I have
an area method.
And I don't need to know the
particular or the type of the
object that I'm calling
the area method on.
Right?
Python is going to take
care of that for me.
I can just iterate through this
bag of shapes, call the
area method, and I can get
a sum of the areas.
That's what polymorphism gives
to me, is it allows me to
treat objects uniformly.
It allows the objects to change
their behavior based on
the particular type of object
that I'm using.
But I don't need to know
the particular details.
So it's pretty powerful.
So it's like, if I were to
create a racing game and I
wanted to drive a car, I could
have different models of car.
But my game engine wouldn't need
to know to drive method
to call for.
Like, a Ford car versus a
Chevrolet, all that stuff.
That kind of answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So if there's not an
area function that overrides
it, what is it going to sum
if it just raises a
non-implemented error?
Yeah, if you haven't
redefined.
PROFESSOR: In this example, I'm
using all what are known
as concrete classes.
So they're not abstract.
They all have implementations
of area.
But if I were to say, for some
reason I decided that I wanted
to make something amorphous.
This should raise
an error, right?
Unless I have invalid syntax.
So when it gets to
there, yeah.
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: So what's the
difference between inheritance
and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: They're related.
But what inheritance means is
that if I say that rectangle
inherits from shape, that
means it gets all of its
methods and attributes.
But it's not necessarily
polymorphic in that case.
It's just, it's like saying a
rectangle is a shape so it has
all these characteristics of
a shape and then some.
The polymorphism comes in when I
override the area method and
then I can treat all shapes,
whether they're rectangles,
squares, circles, uniformly
with the area method.
You might--
I'm trying to think of an
example where it would be.
So let's say that I didn't do
this in a class or entered a
way or using classes.
And so I had a really naive
implementation that said,
let's represent them
as dictionaries.
So I have two really stupid
functions here.
And they say they make a circle
and they make a square.
And so really all it's doing
is representing these as
dictionaries.
And the key is side
and radius.
Now, let's say that I want to
have my list of shapes.
I make a square.
I'm going to make a circle.
Another square.
OK, so now I've got a bag or
shapes or a list of shapes.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: Can you [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Spending too
much time on that one.
All right.
So if I were to take
a look at this.
It's going to print out a
bunch of dictionaries.
Now, the question is, what if I
wanted to compute the areas
of these data types?
Using polymorphism, I can just
call dot area on each shape.
But if I wanted to do the same
thing with this code, I would
have to have square area
s, return, d, side.
And then def circle, area,
c, return, 3.14.
9 times c--
I'm already getting
tripped up.
So even this is not so bad,
because if I do something like
this, I can still get
the areas, right?
And I can do this because I know
what's in those positions
in the list.
So.
AUDIENCE: You forgot to close
your parentheses.
PROFESSOR: Oh.
OK.
So it's going to work.
But now, if I want to print out
all the areas of all the
shapes in this loop here, how
am I going to do that?
Because I can't just call square
area of s, because what
if s is a circle It's going to
give me an error, right?
I could get around this by
saying, if radius in s, then I
know it's a circle, right?
Or, side in s.
But you see how the code is
getting kind of ugly now?
I have to know details about
how these different objects
are implemented, how square and
circle are implemented in
the dictionary.
I have to know what type
they are before I
compute their area.
And I can do it, but
it's kind of ugly.
Whereas if I invest a little
bit of time in a class
hierarchy, I can do this
much more easily.
Much more cleanly.
It's a way of abstracting
from the problem.
You don't have to worry
about the details of
the individual shapes.
Did I kill that?
And beat it into the ground.
AUDIENCE: Just for
clarification.
So the point of polymorphism
is just like inheritance,
essentially, kind
of boiled down?
PROFESSOR: The point of
polymorphism is that if you
have a class hierarchy of
objects, you don't need to
know the details of the objects,
of what specific type
an object is.
As long as you know that
in the case of--
AUDIENCE: So long as there
exists a method
that you want to use.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Where it inherits
from that class,
you could use it.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So in this particular example,
shape has an area method.
And I have a bunch of concrete
subclasses of shape that have
all overridden the
area method.
And they do it in
different ways.
You compute the area differently
for a rectangle
versus an ellipse.
I don't have to worry about
which particular shape it is.
I just call the area method, and
I don't have to do all the
checking that I do here.
Where I look at, is this a
circle, is this a square.
I don't know, so I'm not
going to compute that.
AUDIENCE: How do you
avoid the checking?
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: See?
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK, Great.
Yeah.
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
Anyone lost?
Any other questions?
So that actually touched
on a couple of topics.
So we saw exceptions here.
Is there anyone who wants
to see anything else on
exceptions?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between pass and continue?
PROFESSOR: Pass and continue?
OK.
So the question is what's
the difference
between pass and continue.
So when you have pass, this is
basically a null command.
It's a do nothing command.
I can actually run this
code right now.
And it will do absolutely
nothing useful.
But it also won't complain.
It's a placeholder.
Sometimes--
so a lot of times you'll
see in your code
something like this.
Let's x equals 150.
If x mod 2 equals 0, pass else,
do something useful.
So we see this a lot
in your p-sets.
It's not a slam on
you or anything.
But you could simplify
this by saying--
but the way that you
conceptualize a problem forced
you to have this if statement.
And then you didn't have
anything useful to put in
here, so you had to put
a pass in order to
make Python not complain.
So, let's be a little less
flip and more concrete.
It's getting late, I'm
getting punchy.
All right.
So if I were to run this now,
it's not going to print
anything because it hit
the pass command.
Now let's make this on.
So if we've verified that this
code works and that I'm not
blowing smoke.
Now, let's take out the pass.
Python's going to complain.
Why?
Because after this if
line, here it's
expecting a block of code.
But there's nothing there.
The pass keyword give you
a do nothing command.
It says, I don't really have
anything to say here, but you
want me to put something
here so I'm going to
put something here.
But it doesn't do anything.
So that's pass.
so It's a placeholder,
is the basic answer.
Now, continue is different.
Because continue actually has
a function that is useful.
Let's say that I'm not too
familiar with the range
command, and I don't know that
I can specify a step.
And I want to print out
all the odd integers.
And I also am going to restrict
myself and say that I
can't use an else or something
of that nature.
So I'm going to handicap
myself.
This x-range --
is x-range cool?
So.
I only want to print
out odd numbers.
Or we can do it like this.
Either/or, it doesn't matter.
So, comment this.
What continue does is it, if
you're within a loop, as we
are here with this for loop,
tells Python if it sees a
continue statement, do not
continue beyond this point
within the block of the loop.
Go instead and perform the next
iteration of this loop.
Go to the top of this loop.
So, what this code should do,
I'm hoping, in case I don't--
I might have a bug--
it should print out
the odd integers.
So what's happening is that when
the integer is even, it's
hitting this continue
statement.
And this is telling Python, go
back up to the top of this for
loop and do the next
iteration.
AUDIENCE: If you were to
have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So if I
just had pass?
It'll print all the integers.
That work?
Anyone confused?
AUDIENCE: You could also have
your code if not that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but
[INAUDIBLE].
There are some schools of
thought that say that continue
is something that disturbs
the flow of code
and should be avoided.
I don't subscribe to that.
I think that if it makes your
code clearer, then use it.
Which is to say that, yeah, you
can rewrite a lot of your
code to not use continue.
OK, do we need to
go over anything
with linguistic issues?
Are we good on classes?
AUDIENCE: Can we go over
exceptions, please?
PROFESSOR: So there is a
question on exceptions.
So exceptions are another
way of flow control.
And if I can pull up my source
file, I have an example of
handling exceptions.
There we go.
Exceptions give you
a way of handling
certain errors that occur.
So, the easiest one to come
up with is division by 0.
So normally, if you would
do a division by 0 --
so I'm going trying
to divide 10 by 0.
The universe won't end, but
Python will be very unhappy.
In programs that are more
complex that the ones that
we've been writing, division
by 0 happens but you don't
necessarily want the program
to crash, right?
You want to be able to handle
that error in a
semi-graceful way.
And in this particular example,
with a division by 0,
we can do that with
exceptions.
So let's say that instead of the
program crashing I want to
print out a nicer error message
rather than everything
in big red.
I say, well, you divided by 0
so maybe you should change
your numbers.
The way I capture, or catch this
exception, is I have a
tribe keyword, a colon,
and then I have
this block of code.
This is the code that could
potentially raise an exception
where the error might occur.
This code could be-- in this
case, it's just straight up
assignment and division.
It could be a function that
raises the exception.
It doesn't matter.
The point is that there's an
exception that might occur.
If an exception occurs, then
Python is going to look past
this block of code here at
these except statements.
And it's going to look at the
type of exception it has.
In this case it's a by 0
division error, and it's going
to match the exception against
whatever type this is.
And you can put inside here
whatever code you want in
order to handle this
exception.
So in this case I'm just
printing divided by 0.
I could be rude and
I could say--
see, can't even spell.
So I can handle this exception
however I want.
But the program's not
going to crash.
And this program's actually not
going to really convince
you of that, but you see that--
the first thing you see
here is that there's no big red
blaring message that says
you have an exception.
It's all code that
I've written.
And I could even be
silent about it.
I could say, I'm not going
to say anything.
I'm just going to
fail silently.
Tell me it's all good.
It's not going to tell
me I divided by 0.
It can come in handy if I
like have an input loop.
So let's say I'm going to do a
little bit more, be a little
bit more creative and do--
oh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
How does it [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's an internal
Python thing.
So if you want to learn about
all the wonderful exceptions
that Python provides you in its
class library, you can go
to the Python documentation.
Or you can even do
a Google search.
Of course, Chrome is being very
slow, and the network's
probably down.
So built-in exceptions.
So these are all the exceptions
that Python has.
And you can use these too.
Let's say that, let me get back
to my contrived example.
I want to create a
loop that says--
let's say that I want to catch,
I don't want to divide
even numbers for some reason.
What do we have here?
What can we find?
I think there's a value error.
There we go.
So let's say that I'm going
to raise a value error.
And I am actually going
to do this this way.
So I've created a function
that's not going to allow me
to input even numbers.
It's going to raise a value
error if I enter in a 2 or a 4
or whatever.
But, if I do enter in an odd
number it is just going to
return that number to me.
So I'm going to use
that function now.
And I'm just going to do the
silly thing and divide, do a
division, and print it out.
So if I comment out this code
up here and I comment this
out, and I run this, so--
let's do 3.
That's interesting.
Apparently Python is a little
constipated right now.
We edit this during the summer,
so we can take that
out, I think.
All right.
So it does what we
expected it to.
It's going to keep on prompting
us for numbers and
it's going to divide them for
us and give us the answers.
So we've got a really dumb
calculator here.
Except when I try to do even
numbers, because my calculator
is really, really dumb.
So it's going to raise
a value error.
And it raises the value error
in this function here.
I can handle this, though,
because I know how.
So what should I type here?
OK.
AUDIENCE: If you wanted to
specifically catch that error.
But you could just leave
it as except, and it
would catch any error?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So if any error
were to be thrown, then
[INAUDIBLE].
But if you wanted specifically
to say, OK, the value error
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what she was saying is
that I could do this.
I don't have to specify what
error I'm expecting.
I could say--
But it's not going
to give me any
detail about what happened.
And what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to say that if I
have an exception then I'm
just going to repeat my
getting of the numbers.
So, let's say that I do this.
Something happened, not
really specific.
Nothing happened?
OK, I divided all right.
AUDIENCE: What if you put
in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Would it also come back in
case something happened?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a good question.
Something happened, but
we don't know what.
We know we have a bug, because
an exception was thrwn.
But we don't know what it is.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
never going to crash.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's never going to crash.
AUDIENCE: So a useful example
of when to use this, would
that be like [INAUDIBLE], and
you have the list to choose
from the letters [INAUDIBLE]
it would
remove each of the guesses?
If you accidentally guess
something that
you've already guessed?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you can raise
an exception to say, already
guessed this.
AUDIENCE: As opposed to the
program, that first one I ran,
I accidentally did the same
letter again, and the whole
program just crashed.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So you can raise an
exception for whoever's
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can catch any errors
that were raised.
So we've got a couple
of exceptions
that are raised here.
And actually this program
can crash.
Oh, wait.
No, it can't.
Because [INAUDIBLE].
It thinks [INAUDIBLE].
Silly Python.
So it's not going
to crash at all.
We did a really good
job, right?
So now we want to get a little
bit more specific so I'm going
to catch a value error.
So I'm only going to handle this
one type of exception.
Because--
so it still works.
A, something happened.
But now we know that it's
because I did something silly.
And, now I can break the program
because this keyboard
interrupt, that's actually
an exception.
When you hit Control-C,
it's going to break
you out of the program.
But because we're catching
that exception
it just kept going.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
make an exception [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Wait, what?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: I'm quoting the
girls over there, so.
AUDIENCE: Are you?
PROFESSOR: Uh-oh.
So something happened.
Oh, wow.
How did that happen?
Oh, I know how that happened.
What am I missing here?
So I caught the keyboard
interrupt, right?
I didn't go to the
top of the loop.
So what happened is, it tried
to execute this, but num2
hadn't been defined.
So we're going to kick
me back up to the
top of the loop here.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
It's a clingy program.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It is a clingy program.
Anyway.
So, does everyone get the idea
of what the exceptions are?
So I don't have to
go any more?
AUDIENCE: In this except up
there, there's always
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But what does
this [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So When you get an
exception, when an exception
is raised, it's actually
an object.
So there's an object that's
associated with it.
And in a lot of cases you
really don't have to be
concerned about it, but
sometimes you want some
additional information.
So these are not very
interesting exceptions, but
some exceptions might have some
additional diagnostic
information.
So if you were, say, logging
the run of your program.
And you wanted to diagnose any
exceptions that you caught?
Like, say, you got a generic
exception or you got something
that was kind of odd that
weren't expecting, you could
print out additional
information.
And so E is the name
of that object.
So, I can do this.
Well.
This is because --
if you give it a primer like
that, it's going to put that
message into the exception.
So now I can retrieve it when
the exception is raised.
So if I'm raising the exception,
I can provide
additional information.
So that's the message that I've
put into the exception
when I raised it.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Well, how is that
different-- so is it the same
thing as saying print,
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So this is a really [INAUDIBLE]
example.
So this is just going to
print out whatever
message I passed in.
So when I say this and point to
my screen, I really meant
this and highlighted this.
So, this line is going to print
out this message that I
passed in when I raised
the exception.
Because what I'm actually doing
is, I'm creating a value
error object that has this
message associated with it.
And that's what gets passed up
this exception chain until I
finally handle it. here.
And E holds the reference to
that value error object.
AUDIENCE: So E is
an actual value?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if I do something
like this--
and I print out the type--
you can see that?
It's pretty neat.
But did that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Could
it be anything?
So let's think of something
like this.
Like a list.
AUDIENCE: No.
I meant in your accept value
error dash E. Could you put
any variable there, or
does it have to be E?
PROFESSOR: Oh, any name?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I've always used E.
That's kind of a convention.
But I think you'd be
fine doing that.
E is the convention that
I use, but some
people don't like that.
They're like, you should
name it something
a little bit better.
But honestly, why bother?
Ok.
Are we good with exceptions?
That answer your question?
Any other questions
on exceptions?
AUDIENCE: Is there a built-in
amount of errors you can have?
Like value errors,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE], can you make
up your own?
PROFESSOR: Can you make up
your own exceptions?
Yes.
You can do that.
You can say--
but--
and--
I think this is going to work.
It's been while since I've
defined my own exceptions.
So and again, I can handle it.
So if you ever work on big
systems, a lot of times
they'll have their own exception
hierarchies that
define all sorts of exceptions
for the specific application
you're working on.
Python's built in exceptions
are pretty rich, so--
there we go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I don't
think you do.
It's convention.
I could probably do
this, I think.
Oh, wait.
The only difference--
or the only problem
is, is that now--
see I expect my exception to
have a message attribute.
And I don't have anything
on this.
So I have to do this.
Or something similar, right?
I have to define message
on this.
And I think this'll work.
Well, actually, it does
guard against it.
So yes, you do have to inherit
from exception.
It's one of the few
things that Python
seems to guard against.
So, does that answer
your question?
So we're getting kind of late.
The only other topics that we
have are the simulations and
the distributions and
that's about it.
So, are there any questions
on Monte Carlo methods?
We've kind of done those
to death, right?
Real quick, someone humor me,
what is a Monte Carlo method?
AUDIENCE: An algorithm that
uses random sampling for
trials to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So, it's--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It computes some
value or solution to a problem
using a random process
and repeated trials.
So--
AUDIENCE: Is it almost
brute force?
PROFESSOR: No, it's not what
we call brute force.
I mean, it's like we computed
pi by throwing a dart at a
chalkboard or something
like that.
And it landed in a square, and
we used some sort of analysis
to figure out what pi was based
on that throwing a dart
at a board a million times.
So that's what a Monte
Carlo method is.
Anything that uses random stuff
to compute a value.
A random simulation.
Where'd my chalk go?
And we actually a couple of
Monte Carlo methods when I
showed the solutions
for problems (3)
and (4) on the quiz.
I used a random number generator
in order to figure
out the probabilities
of not rolling a 6
and all that stuff.
And I used the Monte Carlo
method to show me that I was
wrong on my initial answer for
rolling exactly one 6.
So, is everyone comfortable with
coefficient of variation?
Because I did that
first, initially.
Confidence intervals
and levels?
Does anyone have any
questions on that?
AUDIENCE: What is a confidence
interval?
PROFESSOR: What is a confidence
interval and a
confidence level?
OK.
So, let's say I do
a political poll.
Let's say I do a political poll
and I sample 1,000 people
in the population.
And I say 46% of them will
vote for Candidate X. My
margin of error is plus
or minus 4, and my
confidence is 95.
What this is saying is that if
I conduct this poll, the same
poll, sampling 1,000
random people at a
time, over 100 trials--
so I do 100 polls--
what I'm saying is that 95 out
of 100 of those times, my
level of support for Candidate
X will be between
42% and 50%, right?
Basically what you
need to know for
confidence levels and intervals.
The other thing that you need to
know for confidence levels
and intervals is that if you
have a normal distribution,
with a standard deviation
sigma, then 1 standard
deviation from the mean
is going to have--
is that 66 or 67?
Is it 68?
I wrote it down, 68.
Thank you.
And then 2 standard deviations
is going to be 95.
And then 3 standard deviations
is going to be what, 97?
Or is it 99.7?
99.7.
So, but you need to just know
that for normal distributions.
So if this is one standard
deviation, it's saying that 68
of the sample points are going
to be within 1 standard
deviation of this mean.
And then if you have 2 sigma,
then that means 95 are going
to be within 2 sigma
of the mean.
And then if you have 3 sigma,
then 99.7 are going to be
within 3 standard deviations
of the mean.
So I think that's all you
really need to know for
confidence intervals and levels,
and also for normal
distributions.
So we're actually kind of at the
end of the review session.
So does anyone have
any questions
that I haven't answered?
No?
All right.
I'm done.